the Democratic presidential frontrunners
are slamming president Trump's handling
of the corona virus pandemic former Vice
President Joe Biden and senator Bernie
Sanders gave speeches yesterday after
the president's primetime oval office
address on Wednesday and both condemned
to mr. Trump's leadership the
administration's failure on testing is
colossal and it's a failure of planning
leadership and execution the White House
should measure and report each day each
and every day how many tests had been
ordered how many tests have been
completed and how many of tested
positive
the United States government today must
make it clear that in the midst of this
emergency everyone in our country
regardless of income or where they live
must be able to get all of the health
care they need without cost and the
Democratic candidates outlined their own
plans to fight the corona virus crisis
Nikole Killion is here with how the
virus is affecting the campaign so no
surprise that they have their new plans
they want to show that they can be
President but how do you campaign for
voters when you can't have events
absolutely I mean this completely
changes the game and what a difference a
week makes you know at the beginning of
this week these candidates had a full
roster of events and now there's
virtually nothing on their schedule and
so in the case of both the Biden and
Sanders campaigns we now know that their
staffers are going to have to work from
home we know in the case of Sanders
they're no longer going to have
large-scale events that they're not
going to do door-to-door canvassing in
the case of Biden again their staffers
will be working from home starting
Saturday you also have them closing
their campaign offices and the Trump
campaign also making changes to earlier
this week they told us it was going to
be business as usual they were going to
keep these big rallies that the
president loved so much and now they're
also giving workers the option of
working from home
they're also no longer at least for now
doing any public events or public
rallies of those have since been
counting we've got a debate this weekend
with no live audience
what are they hoping to accomplish there
well it'll be an interesting dynamic
especial
after our last debater but certainly I
think we'll see a more substantive
debate a debate certainly focused on the
issues but not having that live
component very well James Nicole thank
you very much